Hello everybody.
Welcome to the webinar.
This is Peter Cooper.
This is the insider's guide to the new My
Bibliography.
With me today are Sherry Bailey and Rana Morris,
and Sherry is going to be our presenter today.
Today you will receive a lot of information
on how to navigate this new system.
I want to thank each of you for joining us.
Thank you for your patience as we go through
these growing pains together.
I am from NCBI user services and I am your
advocate in providing your feedback, suggestions,
and reporting any issues.
With that said take a moment to write down
the email address to provide your suggestions
and feedback on what we are doing right and
how we can improve.
info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
Let's get started.
For those of you who are new to My NCBI, I
want to quickly go over reasons why you should
get an account.
We have videos on our YouTube channel and
on-line manuals which provide step-by-step
directions for each of these tools.
The main reason why we are here today is to
discuss creating and managing citations within
My Bibliography.
One of the easiest ways to log into your account
is to directly go to PubMed.gov.
If you don't already have an account Go to
PubMed.gov click register for an account,
follow the prompts, click the activation link
which is sent to the email address, now you're
ready to log in.
We have officially logged into my NCBI.
On the dashboard there are many different
portlets such as the ability to have your
saved searches run automatically, create collections
that you can share, create custom filters,
create bio sketches, and see your recent activity
as long as you are loged into your account
at the time of your searches.
Let's get back to My Bibliography which is
accessed by clicking the manage My Bibliography
link.
Once you have citations, you may see a spinning
icon.
Do not wait for it to finish.
Go ahead click manage My Bibliography.
Now we are at the My Bibliography page.
On the upper right hand side, if you click
the username, you will find the login information,
the dashboard which we just came from, publications
in My Bibliography which is the screen we
are on, account settings, here's where you
can update your password, email address, link
accounts like the institution's credentials,
ERA commons HRA, and Google to name a few.
You have the ability to invite others to manage
your account.
Of course, you can log out.
Next in the gray [blue] box, you can see the
name listed on your account.
In this case the first name is ncbi and the
last name is user.
Beneath the gray box if you have an award
such as eRA commons for grants, or HRA grants,
icons will appear here.
This is another way to verify that your award
information is correctly linked to your account.
All new accounts are automatically set to
private.
If you wish to share your bibliography with
others, click on the make your bibliography
public link, to reveal the public URL.
You have the option to toggle the link on
and off if you wish you restrict viewing.
To share or not to share, is completely under
your control.
Before we go any further, if you run into
any issues the support center is a click away.
You will find self-help articles and the ability
to contact the helpdesk.
Let's add a few citations.
The first option is from PubMed.
There are numerous ways to search PubMed.
For example, you can run and author search
by using the full name or last name and initials,
or even a partial title as I entered here.
Click Search PubMed, you have the results
and in this case it is one result.
This is the exact title I was looking for.
I will check the box and add that to the bibliography.
I will then have a confirmation saying it
was successfully added as well as my checkbox
is grayed out.
From here I can repeat the process as many
times as I want, then exit out.
You may also add citations from a file.
The file must be in the RIS format most reference
managers can convert the citations to RIS.
As you can see you're given a confirmation
box on how many records have been uploaded
and updated.
Last but not least, is adding citations manually.
You have the ability to add citations of articles
not appearing in PubMed, books,patents, software
and other citations.
We have a few citations let's manage them.
First we will go over the features of both
types of accounts that they have in common,
meaning, those accounts that are linked to
granting agencies like eRA Commons and HRA
and those that are not .In Manage citations,
there are two different types of drop downs,
the account that is private, meaning I have
not activated my public URL, which is seen
here, and accounts that show the public URL.
The difference is set to public and set to
private.
Public citations which the title implies can
be seen in the public URL.
The private label is for those that you do
not want to be seen in the public URL.
Let me give you an example.
A PI who is not the author on a manuscript
but the award funded the manuscript will use
the private label which is seen on the first
citation, for the citation.
Yes, those of you who had an account previously,
the private label has taken the place of other
citations.
The PI is responsible for reporting the grant
but only wants to see items they authored
in the public URL.
Otherwise, you will use the private label.
Back to manage citations, we have copied to
a collection This is a great option if you
wish to have separate collections to share
without sharing your entire bibliography.
You can add citations to this collection as
seen here.
Only PubMed citations can be copied into this
collection.
Finally you can delete citations, you can
export some or all of the citations to a RIS
file.
Back to the homepage.
You may also at times encounter a warning
message.
This occurs when there is either duplicate
citations or you have a citation that may
match a citation appearing in PubMed.
You have two choices, you can hide the warning
or you can resolve it.
To resolve the the conflict, click the conflict
link determine if the citations are the same,
not on the list or save the decision for another
day.
In this particular case, the citations are
the same.
Just the author names are out of order.
What happens if you accidentally dismissed
the warning box or you discover duplicate
citations?
It's an easy fix.
Step number one, locate duplicate citation.
Write down the PMID number.
You need this later.
Step number two, click edit citation of the
manual citation.
A pop up box will appear, locate the type
field and use the drop-down box and select
PMID.
Next in unique ID, you will write down or
type in excuse me, the PMID number.
You will receive confirmation box verifying
that you have the right citation, then you
simply click, yes.
We have one problem solved.
Let's move on to the right side of the screen
for filtering and sorting citations.
The search box located on the upper right
with this you can search by PMCID, PMID, article
title, whole or partial, author name, DOI
or journal title.
Let me repeat that again, you can search by
PubMed ID, PubMed Central ID, article titles,
whole or partial, author name, DOI and journal
title.
May also sort the bibliography by recently
updated citations meaning, recently added
to your account.
By publication date, or by author name in
descending or ascending order.
So far we have reviewed what the accounts
have in common.
Let's take a quick look at accounts that have
linked awards.
Under manage citations, there is manage awards,
and the ability to create a compliance report.
By using the manage awards link you can quickly
add awards to multiple citations and/or multiple
awards to citations.
Let's see this in action.
First select the citations here, and then
you will go to manage citation assign awards,
you will assign the awards and you have the
ability to search for other words if the awards
are not your own.
In this particular one we selected two awards,
and the information has been saved, verified
here.
We will close the citation window.
Let's take a look at the first citation that
we selected.
The count did not change, because one of the
awards was the same so instead of three, I
have two.
Meaning that I selected the same award twice.
It will automatically collapse.
Before we create a compliance report, let's
talk about compliance.
I'm sure you noticed the boxes on the side,
and they also correspond to the icons in the
gray box above.
The question Mark means that public access
is not defined.
The exclamation point lets you know the citation
is noncompliant.
The arrow indicates the citation is in process
and receiving a PMC ID.
The green checkmark indicates it has received
the PubMed central ID and is in compliance.
Let's say you wish to see citations that are
in process.
Simply click on the blue arrow located in
the gray box above, to display only those
citations.
Our grants are attached and we are ready to
create a compliance report.
To start, we will select filter citations.
Next we will select the grant, select the
citations, go to manage citations, click compliance
report, fill out the form which includes first
name, middle name, last name, starting page
number, if applicable, and you click download
the PDF, which appears here.
One of the last features I want to show you
today is the ability to sort all of your records
by public access.
Which is also found in the sorting field.
If you have any remaining questions take a
moment to type them out into the chat box
because this concludes our tour of My Bibliography.
I have one last thing to show you.
Coming soon is a more advanced filtering,
which will be available in about two weeks
or so.
Grant holders can filter by multiple grants
and everyone can filter citations by citation
type, public and private.
This is my final request before we take questions.
We need your help to make our product better.
As you think of features you and others can
benefit from please write us.
info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
I want to thank you again for joining me,
and on behalf of the NCBI User Services we
look forward to hearing from you.
[Rana Morris] Hi Sherry, this is a pretty
common question that came in fairly early.
As you make updates to the website to My Bibliography
and other accounts, are their accounts and
account information automatically transferred?
Do we need to worry about updating the account
every time the user interfaces change?
[Sherri Bailey] They do not.
Everything should be in its proper place even
though the interface may change.
[Rana Morris] Another question, Is there a
plan to make a change in the number of items
displayed per page or it will always be listed
as is.
[Sherri Bailey] That's a perfet suggestion.
Use the email on the screen now.
info@ncbi.nlmnih.gov
Please suggest it.
We make changes based on user needs.
[Rana Morris] There are a number of librarians
online who do training for My bib, SciEnCV,
and public access compliance.
They want to create slide sets for the presentations.
They want to know if it is possible to get
a fake account so they can create those slides?
What is a reasonable way to do that?
[Sherri Bailey] write into the email address
you see and we can check with the development
team to see what we can do.
[Rana Morris] They are interested and excited
about the changes, and want to know if there
are plans to improve SciEnCV since they are
connected?
[Sherri Bailey] Stay tuned.
It is happening and will be coming in the
near future.
[Rana Morris] There are a number of suggestions
that have come in.
Other people have mentioned that they do training
and have validated some of the other features
and we will take all of those and bring them
to the team to see what they can do.
Are you updating the my NCBI Help with information
about making the citations public and private?
[Sherri Bailey] Yes.
It should be available now if you go to the
My Bibliography documentation, it should show
all the current screenshots that I showed
you today.
www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/books/NBK53595
[Rana Morris] If the citations are appearing
where the user is a PI but not an author,
they are on a grant but not an author, can
you go over that one more time?
What do you set private?
[Sherri Bailey] If the URL is already public,
it will show everything there.
A PI who is not the author on the grant what
you want to do is select those citations,
go to manage citations, you want to set those
citations to private so it will not show in
the public URL.
[Rana Morris] Is there currently a limit that
we know about for the number of citations
that can be held in My Bib?
[Sherri Bailey] Great question.
It is part of the reason why we updated to
My Bibliography 3.0.
There is not a limit currently, you will have
multiple pages.
[Rana Morris] That will help the researchers
who have hundreds and hundreds of citations.
Is there any intention to add additional features
in addition to the filter feature you showed
for specific grants?
Are there other sort options or features that
you are thinking about or would you consider
taking in additional sort or feature references?
For sort, maybe things like most relevant
to grants, etc.
[Sherri Bailey] This is why we ask for your
feedback.
We want to make this product as usable to
you not just what we think you need.
This is why we ask for feedback.
We want to make this product the best it can
be to fit your needs.
[Rana Morris] Here is another question about
public and private.
It sounds like something that would be good
to address, not only in FAQs but in documentation
on the system.
One of the librarians says this is happening
to a client of mine.
NIH told him he needs to remove citations
appearing in My Bibliography for those which
he is not an author.
Is that what the private thing is supposed
to do?
By identifying them as private, remove them
from the citation.
[Sherri Bailey] It removes it not from the
citation list.
Everything will be there.
Underneath the citation itself it will say
private.
If the PI or the person uses the actual link,
the public URL, the only thing they will see
are those things that are considered public.
Anything with a private label will be hidden.
[Rana Morris] We used to be able to select
the view citations in PubMed.
This is a useful feature.
The citations could be sent to EndNote, will
you add this feature back to My Bibliography?
Or is there another way to do it?
[Sherri Bailey] There's not another way to
do that, if you can please write that down
and stick that in our suggestions, we would
appreciate it.
[Rana Morris] There are a lot of suggestions.
We will compile all of these and send them
in to the team.
I have some suggestions for SciEnCV too, particularly
about orchid integration.
Is the email address,
info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
also the email address they should send an
suggestions for SciEnCV and My NCBI?
[Sherri Bailey] Yes.
Use this address.
This is not limited to My Bibliography.
You can use it for anything dealing with My
NCBI or NCBI in general.
We will make sure it gets to the right development
team.
[Rana Morris] There are a couple additional
questions that are technical in nature.
We will include those in the FAQ document
so the answers can be written down for you.
That will be out in about a week or so on
the FTP site.
Thank you very much for participating in this
webinar.
She tuned for additional webinars throughout
the year.